we tried to get our boys interested I
think weren't interested they resisted
okay and this is always a problem it's
as parents you'd like to have your kids
learn languages yeah
they may or they may not if they get
interested they'll learn
so my younger son who is also the CEO of
Link okay he also wasn't interested but
he ended up being a professional hockey
player whoa and ice hockey and so he
played in Europe and he played in Japan
so he played in Italy he played in
Austria he played in Switzerland and he
played in Japan for 10 years and so when
you're on a team
you're with other people more or less
the same age you're on the team together
so there's a great feeling of
togetherness and all of a sudden you
realize that speaking a language is
useful and so then now he manages it
quite well in in Italian and German and
Japanese wow because he realized that it
was useful sure and and he was with
people who he wants